bang-bang what's up guys welcome to
lunch money what's today Tuesday
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right coming to you every day
around noon I've got the beautiful and
intelligent play Tamara Nova with us
here today
today she looks like a walking billboard
for a subpar football team we are ready
to roll baby
go Gators what's going on with the
Treasury tomorrow three trillion dollars
and three months to face a pandemic US
federal debt do you know how much they
have trillions 25 trillion dollars is a
US federal debt so here's how to explain
this entire situation imagine if you are
an individual and you have twenty five
trillion dollars of debt right so I owe
twenty five trillion dollars to other
people this year I'm going to make
whatever money I make is income but I'm
gonna spend even more so I need to
borrow more money right that's what the
federal government is doing this year it
was estimated at the beginning of the
year there's gonna be a one trillion
dollar deficit so they were gonna spend
a trillion dollars more than they
actually made so we're already gonna
lose money in the debt was gonna get
bigger this year then coronavirus it
when coronavirus hit they had to step in
and help people so that helped small
businesses there to bail out people they
had to help on unemployment insurance
etc so what ends up happening in that
situation is that they're gonna have to
borrow more money right in order to fund
some of this stuff they're borrowing
unprecedented levels of yes but here's
the key at the same time that they've
got to spend a lot more all of their
revenue is going down as well so if you
look at like the state local level
something like the Subway ridership goes
down 95 percent they make less money but
the federal government level now what
they're gonna do is between April and
June they're gonna borrow three trillion
dollars two point nine nine trillion
dollars so okay so who is the government
borrowing from ah this is the key
question so the way the government
borrows money is they basically say I'm
gonna issue a bond right a treasurer
bond and when I issue that I guarantee
to pay a certain amount of money in
interest on a preset time period so
there's a three-month Treasury bond
there's five years thirty years etc
right now the reason why they're
borrowing so much money is because it's
very cheap to borrow the money right if
you look at interest rates interest
rates got slashed and so right now every
single bond that the Treasury will issue
is some 1% interest rate except for one
so the reason why this is important is
twofold one is twenty five trillion
dollars of debt they're gonna actually
increase the deficit the new estimate is
by another three point five trillion
dollars oh she's going down the rabbit
hole so a whole key is that we're gonna
expand our debt by over ten percent this
year alone right so it's like being in
debt and taking on more debt nobody
would do that but that's what the
government's do but the key piece of
this is when they borrow so much money
at low interest rates it's like saying
if I borrow $100 at 2% I owe two percent
or two dollars right two percent of $100
but if I borrowed $100 at one percent I
owe one dollar what they're actually
doing though is they're they're being
very smart they're saying we're gonna
borrow $200 at one percent and now I
still owe that two dollars from their
first example but I got double the
amount of money for right it's a nice
accentuate them to their borrow three
trillion dollars while rates are really
low here is the whole key it's a mirage
of confidence because guess what if you
were to lend me money the only way you
would do this if you thought I was gonna
pay you back yeah what happens the
second you think I can't pay you back
you're not gonna lend me money and also
you're saying give me my [ __ ] money
back right and so the big concern here
is at what point does the US government
actually default on its debt because it
is impossible absolutely government
default in the past for sure it is
impossible for the US government to pay
this debt back 28 at the end of this
year is gonna be over twenty eight
trillion dollars of debt right where are
they gonna get twenty eight trillion
dollars once the economy starts running
again maybe they even there they don't
want it a surplus they lose money every
year it's an unprofitable
business right the only saving grace of
the US government is that they can print
whatever money they need if the US
government was a company what company
would they be it would be a [ __ ]
investment like think about it's an
unprofitable business with expanding
losses so it would be like saying I'm
gonna invest in the local store they
lose money every year and actually the
problem is getting worse and worse yeah
and they have no plan they have no
intention to solve it we're gonna
continue to lose money
now the reason why government can do
that is because they can print money
back so again the treasurer is gonna
borrow three trillion dollars in the
next 90 days and it's just it's not even
dead right I wrote something this
morning that literally the title is is
it really dead if you've never plan to
pay it back you can call it dead but
again I don't think that they're gonna
default on these specific bonds it's
just all a mirage every time we talk
about this stuff I think of monopoly
yeah there well that not only are they
playing Monopoly but at some point the
US dollars gonna be worth less than the
monopoly think about that in Zimbabwe
there's a hundred trillion dollar or a
hundred trillion dollar Zimbabwe
currency that's crazy that probably gets
you like nothing speaking of money
what's going on Robin Hood so Robin Hood
the popular stock picking app has raised
another crazy big round with 280 million
dollars led by Sequoia and a valuation
of eight point three billion I have a
very hot take on this I know because
you're but you have to disclose why well
I'm an investor in a competitor each
worth each Oro is basically the Robin
Hood of Europe if you will to some
degree um I don't think that wasn't
really a hot take I don't think that
Robin Hood is worth that valuation what
you thinking about is that Sequoia
thinks it's worth that valuation well
actually it's the exact opposite
actually
newsflash what we just saw is all of
these companies were raising money at
incredible valuations what's interesting
is I actually think that this is a down
round in terms of the pre-money
valuation the last time they raised
money what I think was at eight point
five billion dollar valuation and so
it's raising two hundred million at an
eight point three pre-money valuation
job should put it at a or on straights a
flat round billion yes there's basically
a flat round it's not down round
that's what's a hundred million between
friends at those valuations it's
basically a flat round right and look at
the end of the day this is part of
something they should do because what
they're really probably doing is they're
shoring up the balance sheet make sure
they have cash and saying we're not
gonna have to raise money for like two
years
well they're saying that they want to
expand globally with this money when
there's downturn two things happen some
companies they shrink right they go in
the turtle shell the cockroach mode we
talked about or they get hyper
aggressive try steel market share
they're obviously going hyper aggressive
trying to steal a market share we'll see
if it works
but I mean there are the pioneers of
fractional shares and all that
absolutely do you have a Robin Hood
account no I used to though when it
first came out what happened you just
said no I was just like I don't feel
like gambling I don't trust myself
enough I don't trust myself enough to
pick individual stocks but I think their
point is more like educating the
millennial bikini season yeah for sure
all right move it what's going on move
it move it move it move it so Intel is
buying urban mobility platform movement
in a nine hundred million dollar deal
what does that mean what is it urban
mobility platform so move it is
basically this Israeli startup that
looks it analyzes urban traffic patterns
and kind of tells you with a specific
focus on public transit and I think yeah
it gives traffic data to third parties
including uber so it just makes it maps
out the city better well it's not that
hard to analyze the traffic right now
there is none I didn't need 900 million
dollars to do that but actually this is
super interesting for two reasons right
one is it's all data right so they
they've got an ability to suck in the
data and understand the traffic patterns
and then two is my guess is that they're
selling a lot of this to cities around
City Planning here in New York for
example that added attacks so below I
think one hundred and twenty fifth
Street or something there's a tax if you
drive a car or like
see you have to pay a tax once you go
below that street number and then
there's also streets I actually forget
what Street it is but you can't drive
your cars during certain times of the
day so like let's say like between 8 and
noon no one's a lot of drive on that
road because their data is what is
informing that stuff it tells you here's
where all the traffic jams are happening
here's why people can't get through the
tunnel it's actually because of this
other area things like that my question
is in this time of constraint or so we
think why are all these massive deals
being done like what's going on here
because there's dislocation in the
market so let's say I don't know if this
is the case here but let's say that
you're the CEO of move it and you're
sitting there just like Robin Hood just
did and you're like okay I need capital
because I want to expand I can go get
debt capital I can go get equity capital
at somebody can buy equity in my
business or whoa hold on a second we've
got these guys Intel who've got a huge
balance sheet why don't I just sell
majority of my company to them they'll
give me a bunch of resources and then I
can go and do this so like one plus one
equals three or four and so the reason
why a lot of deals get done right now is
because people need capital
there's dislocations in the market and
Intel public things are getting a great
deal and moving either things they're
getting a great deal or they don't have
a lot of other options so you get kind
of consolidation in these time periods
and as I keep saying cash is King and
whoever has the biggest balance sheet
makes the rules and as I say speaking of
getting paid just fine first up Adam
Newman's the former CEO and founder of
we work so he filed a lawsuit against
Softbank for pulling out of that three
billion dollar tender offer what's your
take on this I mean they're all gonna
sue each other I think we work sorry
suing soft thing this is a separate
lawsuit um and I think he's doing it cuz
doesn't that mean that he doesn't get
his million-dollar package so for those
that don't know we work is a company
that they go in they lease let's say an
entire floor of an office building and
they cut it up into smaller pieces and
then rent it month-to-month to a bunch
of businesses and individuals
and they basically take a spread as they
cut up that space atom noon was CEO he
did some ridiculous things a lot of
things that people question kind of the
intentions behind his father the nicest
way to say it I'm sure he's a nice guy
whatever but but definitely got himself
in a bad situation
there was a deal recently that Softbank
stepped in and said they were going to
provide a bunch of financing they were
gonna buy about three billion dollars
worth of equity from existing
shareholders so Adam Newman was read
around a billion dollars of that and
then the other two billion dollars was
investors employees acceptor so give
them some liquidity because the company
and they're not going public as all of
this started to transpire the beginning
of the year and into uh SAT word into
the coronavirus time
Softbank got nervous and they basically
walked away from the deal so there's two
ramifications for this one the financial
ramifications which is those employees
and investors are going to get their
money they're pissed off right a lot of
them we're planning to get that so
that's where you see the company suing
that's where you see Adam Newman suing
the second thing is this is a massive
reputation hit to Softbank I do not
think soft bang makes a comeback from
this really you think this is what makes
soft banks reputation I think that they
were already on the decline from a
reputation standpoint now all of a
sudden you've got your biggest deal this
is your crown jewel and you just told a
founder and all the investors and
employees we were gonna give you three
billion dollars and on the eleventh hour
Cinderella hour we're gonna pull it from
you why would any why would any
entrepreneur ever agree to take money
from them ever again
I feel like they will because they have
a big big pocketbook we don't even have
to start with their biggest LP is Saudi
Arabia as well that's another case III
just like that the chief legal officer
of soft banks said newman's queens were
meritless because under the terms of the
agreement soft bank had no obligation to
complete the tender offer in which
Newman sought to sell 1 billion dollars
in stock so there's two other pieces
that are really interesting one I
actually think South Bank is going to
like win in this case because there are
so many little things that we work and
the company had to do in order for soft
Bank to be obligated to do this so I do
think soft Bank will prevail the second
thing I read just before we jumped on
here I was reading my email real quick
Dan Primack your your previous rival no
damn time a cat Axios wrote something
where I guess part of Newman's lawsuit
is that Softbank went and tried to
negotiate with them and they couldn't
come to an agreement and at some point
Softbank reportedly or allegedly just
removed his signature block from a
document so that happened massive legal
ramifications again that's complete
allegation that I have no proof I just
read it in the newsletter and so there's
a lot of things being thrown around here
that if they end up being true will have
massive legal ramifications I just don't
think that it's gonna be easy to
pinpoint Softbank having to pay its
three billion dollars like we all are
desensitized to numbers okay we just we
didn't print three true the Treasury's
borrowing three trillion the Federal
Reserve's a hold another case they
actually did print like two trillion
which is a whole different situation all
right what's going on speaking of
leaving men in the stories of the world
we go from Adam Newman to Joe exotic go
to Joe exotic Joe exotic will be played
by Nicolas Cage in a new scripted series
Nikki cage baby yeah he's a he's an OG
yeah of course what's your favorite
Nicholas Cage movie Oh God didn't he do
one that was like kind of like the
notebook
alright well might be time not to
Nicolas Cage marks I don't even know
what that is
no but nobody's watching these chick
flicks that you watch Polina loves to
watch like I call them trashy Nicholas
Sparks movies which essentially is the
same movie over and over again they just
changed the characters names but it's
literally the same story every time but
no if Joe exotic of course there was
gonna be a movie or a TV show or
something what I want to know is what's
the financing behind all of this one
who's gonna create it
- does Joe got to get any of this money
and three is anyone gonna hire Joe
exotic as a
a consultant to make sure that they get
all the details right can I just ask
so it's Joe exotic he's not able to see
Tiger king in prison is he i from what I
read this is weeks ago I don't think
that he's actually seen it yet he just
knows that he's famous what does that
mean in terms of him being presently
because he got paid in any way I doubt
that he's getting paid which is wild
because Carol Baskin all of them they're
all I don't think a name were getting
paid there they're just part of the
documentary they disagree do and they
probably signed over their rights here's
the crazy part Joe exotic is gonna go on
a rampage when he gets out and he he is
gonna go from show to show to show and
we're gonna see Joe exotic hitting us
with finger guns and everything on
national television
I don't know when he gets out but when
Joe exotic gets out get off the internet
cuz that guy's gonna go wild he's been
living his whole life trying to be
famous he's so famous right now it's
gonna be all pent up and when he gets
out it is gonna be nuts yeah I can't
believe I mean come on like did he
really run for president nobody got on
like all the shows is running for
president but that's the whole key is
like those news shows are entertainment
they're not really news right like oh
well this guy's got a mullet he's got a
pistol on his hip he's got a bunch of
Tigers yeah this guy might be the
president speaking of Joe exotic let's
talk about his arch nemesis Carroll
Baskin who got tricked so last night we
watched Carroll Baskin gave her first
interview since the show and it was kind
of underwhelming I'm gonna be honest
with you but she got tricked two
youtubers have been with us in in Europe
they basically what they've done is
they've gone I had gotten late-night
show hosts YouTube videos they've
clipped the audio so they'll take what
they did here is they got somebody to
email Carol Baskin and say hey I'm the
producer for Jimmy Fallon's late-night
show we would love to have you come on
Carol Baskin originally said no then she
came back and said okay my daughter said
I should do this we just there
but I'll only do it if we don't talk
about tiger King right which basically
meant she's one talk about the big cats
and her rescue etc and so what they did
the two youtubers he's they took Jimmy
Fallon's videos where he he interviewed
a cat he talked about the movie cats
yeah he literally interviewed a cat one
time so they took all those audio clips
worship where he talks it and says the
word cat and then they waited and when
she came on the screen they basically
said hey Jimmy can see you and hear you
but you can't see him and I'm the
producer and so then they would play the
audio of Jimmy being like so how are the
cats from his previous interviews and
she thought that she was talking to
Jimmy Fallon and she literally gave like
oh the cats are doing great you know we
have 15 cats they're really hungry and
so it's this whole interview where she's
basically talking to pre recordings to
Jimmy Fallon
but like the interview really meant
saving crazy
well she didn't because the questions
were bad I would have clipped it better
just FYI oh she had a great response to
when she got told later on that they
tricked her what she says she has
amazing like PR skills I don't know who
is helping her but she is hello you cats
and kittens oh you stole it from her
true she said I appreciate their
cleverness I mean it was pretty clever
yeah but like you they made her kind of
look like an idiot when they were like
take your flower crown off take put it
back on take it off remember yes but
also I think on top of that this brings
the question but we are headed to a
world where we're gonna have to question
authenticity a video of audio when you
do an interview it's gonna be scary
right because you don't actually know
are you talking to person or you're not
talking to the person are you talking to
a deep fake do you think that you would
have known that was fake of you or her
well I'll give you a direct example I
just did an interview over the weekend
for BBC News and I literally was talking
into a screen I couldn't see anybody I
could just hear the voice and I was I
thought I was on plane uh pulled it up
on her thing so she was watching on yeah
but like they could have tricked me I
know you think that'd be funny yeah why
would that be funny because wait
speaking of Joe exact
be on my side who do you think would
play you in a movie Terrell [ __ ]
basket if you throw me the softball hit
it out of the park every time who would
you want to play unity I know who I'd
want to play me you know who I like I
know he like the bald man No
Oh Jason Statham so you're gonna say no
I put out the Chino oh look he's like a
hundred billion years old I love I hope
to be a hundred million years old one
day Al Pacino he just looks you in the
eye low raspy voice you're just like
never give an inch
all right we've violated the rules we
promise only 20 minutes guys thanks for
watching much money today well while
she's trying to get rich the rest of us
trying to get a lunch money right any
parting words for the people no be nice
to your friends be nice to your friends
get money get paid and the US Treasury
is coming for yo cash we will see you
guys tomorrow